Générique
...
-Bienvenue dans "Ces idées
qui gouvernent le monde".
La planification écologique
sera socio-économique
ou ne sera pas.
Planification écologique,
transition climatique,
transition énergétique,
tout cela concourt au même objectif
de décarbonation de l'économie,
de sobriété de la consommation,
de réduction
des gaz à effet de serre,
de contenir
le réchauffement climatique.
C'est vrai pour la France
comme pour le reste du monde.
En ce qui concerne l'Europe,
un accord pour une économie neutre
en carbone
est prévu pour 2050
avec une étape intermédiaire
en 2030.
Une écologie de progrès,
effective et concrète,
suppose de verdir
les transports, les bâtiments,
l'industrie, l'énergie,
l'agriculture,
à travers une cinquantaine
de leviers d'action recensés
par le plan de planification
écologique dévoilé
par le président Emmanuel Macron.
Que cela soit souhaitable,
nécessaire, coordonné
à travers
les divers secteurs d'activité,
est une évidence
qui ne se discute pas.
Reste à savoir
si cela est envisageable
avec l'ambition politique proclamée
au regard de la masse
considérable d'investissements
évoqués notamment
par le plan Pisani-Ferry Mahfouz
pour France Stratégie.
Et cela alors que la situation
économique de notre pays est
tributaire d'une dette publique
supérieure au produit national brut,
à un déficit endémique
du commerce extérieur,
à un chômage encore élevé
et, "last but not least",
aux conflits sociaux
qui ont malmené la société française
ces dernières décennies.
Face à ce challenge,
je vais vous présenter mes invités
en leur demandant de faire
des propositions d'action
aussi concrètes que possible.
Jean-René Cazeneuve,
vous êtes député,
rapporteur général
de la commission des finances
à l'Assemblée nationale.
Brice Lalonde, vous êtes
ancien ministre de l'Ecologie,
président
d'Equilibre des Energies.
Hélène Peskine, vous êtes
architecte, urbaniste,
secrétaire générale du PUCA.
Jean-Claude Mailly,
vous êtes ancien secrétaire général
de Force Ouvrière.
Vous venez de voir la citation
de Jean Pisani-Ferry :
"Les politiques publiques ne seront
"soutenables que si l'ensemble
de leurs implications économiques
"et sociales sont correctement
prises en compte."
Pensez-vous, M. Cazeneuve,
que la planification écologique,
telle qu'elle se présente
pour la France aujourd'hui,
est-ce qu'elle est soutenable ?
-Alors, est-ce que l'objectif
est soutenable ?
Mais...
-Les objectifs.
-Peut-être en préambule, dire que
je trouve qu'on a beaucoup progressé
ces dernières années
et plus vite qu'on ne le croit.
Dans votre introduction, vous disiez
que tout le monde était convaincu,
mais il y a encore quelques années,
on parlait beaucoup
des climatosceptiques, etc.
Donc le constat maintenant
est partagé par tout le monde.
Le niveau d'investissement
nécessaire,
on peut prendre effectivement
le rapport Pisani-Ferry Mahfouz,
60 milliards
d'investissements supplémentaires
pour la France. Maintenant, l'enjeu,
la marche, les marches sont,
je crois, à peu près
partagées par l'essentiel.
On a aussi
beaucoup progressé
et c'est le travail
qui a été fait par le secrétaire
général
à la planification écologique,
c'est répartir
cet effort par secteur,
répartir cet effort
dans le temps,
par acteur, par sous-action,
par levier. Donc maintenant,
on sait ce que chacun doit faire
ou ce que chacun devrait faire
pour atteindre
cet objectif de neutralité
carbone et de baisse des émissions
de gaz à effet de serre.
La grande question est
comment on soutient cet effort,
quel est le rôle de l'Etat, celui
des collectivités territoriales,
celui des entreprises.
Là, effectivement,
c'est une montagne,
c'est un Everest.
-Pensez-vous que
la situation économique
que connaît la France
peut permettre
cette planification écologique
dans son ambition
et dans ses objectifs ?
-C'est... une grande question.
C'est vrai que, quand vous regardez
l'endettement de notre pays,
dans les propositions
qui sont faites, il faut augmenter
l'endettement. S'il n'y a pas
d'accord européen
pour l'augmenter et accepter
de desserrer un petit peu
les règles européennes,
on peut pas le faire tout seuls,
parce qu'on est déjà
un des mauvais élèves de la classe,
si vous me permettez l'expression.
En matière d'imposition,
qui est aussi un levier,
on est aussi un des pays où le taux
de prélèvement obligatoire est
le plus élevé, donc il faut imaginer
quelque chose au niveau
européen,
mais ces leviers, ils existent.
Il faut les trouver collectivement.
-Hélène Peskine,
qu'en pensez-vous sur ce plan-là ?
C'est-à-dire soutenable
économiquement,
au regard de la situation du pays
et du fait que le remboursement
de la dette est aujourd'hui
le 1er budget français
avant l'Education nationale.
-Pas tout à fait, mais...
Potentiellement.
-Potentiellement.
-On a un peu tendance
à se poser mal la question.
La question est celle de savoir
si le coût de l'inaction est pas
plus élevé que le coût de l'action.
On est bien obligé d'investir
pour éviter des coûts qui seront
sans doute répartis différemment
entre les perdants et les gagnants,
et qui de toute façon
sont inéluctables et même
bien connus et mesurables.
Quand une catastrophe survient,
et de plus en plus d'événements
climatiques en génèrent,
on voit bien que leur coût,
à un moment,
il va falloir
le prendre en charge collectivement.
Dans la mesure où il vaut mieux agir
que ne pas agir,
il faut trouver
les leviers financiers pour agir
avec une forme de justice
dans la répartition
des coûts et des charges
qui doit être aussi liée,
il me semble, à la répartition
des... comment dire,
des émissions
de gaz à effet de serre
à l'habitant, à l'entreprise
ou à la collectivité locale. Si on
regarde la différence entre les 10 %
les plus riches et les 50 %
les plus pauvres, le budget carbone
des 10 % les plus riches à l'année,
c'est à peu près 22 tonnes
par habitant et par an
et c'est 5 tonnes pour les 50 %
des Français les moins riches.
Donc il y a une logique
de politique publique
qui s'adresse à ceux
qui sont les plus polluants
sur cet enjeu
d'émission de gaz à effet de serre.
Une partie de cette population
est capable encore aujourd'hui
d'être plus mise à contribution
dans la lutte
contre le changement climatique,
dont ils seront
également les victimes,
par contre, les pauvres le seront
plus vite.
Il y a une logique à avoir,
sans aller dans les chiffres mêmes,
de répartition
de la charge et du poids
de cet investissement. Il vaut mieux
se projeter dans cette réflexion
plutôt que dans le montant
qu'il faudra
investir et finalement,
comment dire, le niveau du curseur
en valeur absolue et la capacité
pour la France à le respecter.
-Jean-Claude Mailly, vous avez eu
des responsabilités sociales
à Force Ouvrière.
Comment vous répartissez
la priorité
entre social et écologie
dans un cadre économique qui est
contraint en ce qui concerne
la France et d'autres pays
européens, sauf peut-être
l'Allemagne ?
-Comme vous le disiez, plus personne
ou peu de personnes contestent
la nécessité d'investir,
de prendre en compte
les questions environnementales,
de faire la transition, etc.,
mais cette transition,
comme d'autres dossiers,
n'est acceptable
que s'il y a un équilibre
et une prise en compte
des questions sociales.
C'est des trucs très basiques.
De temps en temps,
on m'interroge sur Paris,
"M. Mailly, il faut nous aider,
parce que 1er janvier 2025,
"j'ai plus le droit de rouler
avec mon diesel dans Paris,
"je peux pas me payer d'autre
voiture, je suis retraité, etc."
C'est un exemple, hein, c'est
un épiphénomène, mais en même temps,
si on ne prend pas en considération
les conséquences sociales
pour les individus et notamment
pour ceux qui n'ont pas les moyens
de faire les travaux
dans leurs appartements ou maisons,
ça risque de créer plus de tension
et d'être un frein à la transition
écologique. C'est un élément clé.
Deuxième élément, effectivement,
c'est le problème économique.
Dégager, il faut les dégager,
ces 60 milliards, c'est évident,
mais comment on fait ?
On peut certes
comme le dit
le rapport Pisani-Ferry,
allons-y sur l'emprunt,
oui, mais à quel moment les taux
d'intérêt vont descendre ?
A quel moment ce sera soutenable
financièrement ? Vous pourrez
me confirmer ou m'infirmer
que l'horizon 2027, on pourrait être
à 75 milliards dans les conditions
actuelles de frais de remboursement
d'intérêt sur notre dette.
Comment on règle ce problème ?
En situation de croissance,
même si on fait mieux
que l'Allemagne,
c'est pas terrible, on tourne à 0,1,
etc., bon, au trimestre. Donc ça,
ça veut dire poser
les problèmes de fiscalité.
Je suis d'accord,
à un moment donné,
ceux qui ont les moyens, ça peut
être du côté des entreprises. Je dis
toujours, c'est pas nouveau, une
grande entreprise peut légalement
par des systèmes
d'optimisation fiscale payer
8 % d'impôts sur les sociétés,
la PME, elle est
à 25. Voilà. Qu'est-ce qu'on fait ?
On traite ces questions ?
Si on veut financer,
c'est pareil, les réformes
ne passent que
s'il y a un consentement.
Alors, il est pas à 100 %,
mais quand il y a pas consentement,
ça coince.
-Brice Lalonde,
vous qui avez exercé
des responsabilités ministérielles,
comment vous appréhendez
la situation présente sous l'angle
socioéconomique ?
-D'abord, je pense
que c'est un projet enthousiasmant
pour la jeunesse française
et les Français.
Décarboner, être parmi les premiers
à réussir cette décarbonation,
la France a déjà fait
la moitié du chemin.
On se rend pas assez compte de ça.
On a fait la moitié
du chemin pour les objectifs 2030.
Et cette année, on a baissé
de 4 % déjà. C'est inouï.
On n'a jamais baissé autant.
Donc, c'est apporter,
voilà, c'est apporter.
L'ensemble des entreprises
du CAC 40 est mobilisé,
c'est incroyable, beaucoup plus
que dans d'autres pays.
Alors, évidemment, il va falloir
prendre des dispositions
et sans doute
faut-il s'évader du carcan
européen budgétaire,
sans doute faut-il
que la transition écologique
ou la décarbonation fasse
l'objet d'un budget à part,
un peu comme la Libération.
On fait la Caisse nationale
de l'Energie,
on s'endette et on rembourse
sur les bénéfices et revenus futurs.
On n'y arrivera pas autrement.
Et évidemment, il faut de la justice
sociale. Et il y a beaucoup
de maladresses.
Donc corrigeons-les.
Les ZFE pour empêcher
les gens qui sont à la campagne
d'entre en ville,
c'est ridicule.
On a fait une erreur.
On n'a pas pensé aux effets pervers.
Même chose pour les bâtiments
et les passoires thermiques.
Le thermomètre est
mal adapté si vous voulez.
Donc on peut pas d'un coup
dire aux gens, c'est terminé,
virez, partez de là,
vous pouvez plus louer.
Il faut le faire
plus intelligemment.
Mais c'est parfaitement possible,
c'est passionnant et la France est
plutôt bien partie.
C'est pas une mauvaise élève.
Si vous regardez les émissions
françaises par habitant,
on est plutôt bien placés.
-Brice Lalonde,
vous avez parlé de carcan européen.
La réduction
envisagée des gaz à effet de serre
en vue de réaliser
la neutralité carbone
en 2050, est-ce qu'elle vous paraît
réalisable au regard
de ce qu'on attend déjà en 2030
avec une réduction
de plus de moitié ?
Pensez-vous qu'avec ce qu'on a fait
aujourd'hui, cela est réalisable ?
-C'est réalisable,
mais on n'est pas obligés
de surenchérir.
L'accord de Paris nous dit, il faut
viser la neutralité carbone
dans la seconde moitié du siècle.
L'Europe nous dit,
on va pas attendre
la seconde moitié du siècle,
on va faire dès 2050.
Bon, alors, on est peut-être
à quelques années près,
c'est pas gravissime. Donc,
ce qui compte maintenant,
c'est la constance.
Il faut être constant, cohérent
et que ce soit
clair et net pour tous.
Il faut surtout pas bouger
toutes les 5 minutes.
On a eu tendance
à faire ça trop souvent.
-Jean-René Cazeneuve ?
-J'adore cet enthousiasme,
je... j'espère que vous avez raison
et je respecte trop ce que vous avez
fait pour le mettre en doute.
Je crois qu'il y a
une prise de conscience.
J'appartiens à une génération
qui était à côté de la plaque
sur le sujet.
Je trouve qu'il y a une montée
en puissance collective.
On ne peut réussir
que si tout le monde participe.
On a tendance aujourd'hui,
trop en France,
à se retourner vers l'Etat.
L'Etat doit nous aider. Non.
Si on veut réussir,
les entreprises doivent s'y mettre
et elles le font,
que les collectivités territoriales
s'y mettent,
que les foyers s'y mettent,
et ils s'y mettent,
tout seuls
ou les enfants les engueulent.
Je trouve
que cette prise de conscience
et ce changement, on le voit,
la sobriété énergétique,
quand l'année dernière, on a dit,
il faut baisser notre consommation
électrique, on l'a baissée
de 10 % collectivement.
Je voudrais rebondir sur ça,
parce que c'est assez intéressant
et ça montre beaucoup de choses.
Il se trouve
que j'étais rapporteur général
de la loi climat et résilience
qui n'a que deux ans.
Cette loi climat et résilience,
c'est quoi,
sa genèse ? Elle répondait
aux attentes des Français,
la convention
citoyenne. D'accord ?
Et dans cette loi, on a mis
le ZAN, les passoires thermiques,
les ZFE,
tous ces sujets dont on parle. Bon.
On nous a engueulés à l'époque,
on n'avait pas respecté à la lettre,
on n'avait pas écouté
les Français,
il y avait rien dans cette loi, etc.
On est en train de l'appliquer,
2 ou 3 ans après,
et évidemment, on s'aperçoit
de la complexité. Quand on veut
mettre les ZFE, on s'aperçoit
que sans accompagnement,
ça se fait pas.
Les passoires thermiques,
et Dieu sait qu'on a prévenu,
que c'est échelonné dans le temps,
que c'est une petite partie,
mais il y a des difficultés
à le faire. Et je vous parle pas
du Zéro Artificialisation Nette
dans les territoires ruraux
comme les miens,
où on a l'impression qu'on arrête
toute possibilité de développement.
Donc on voit bien que... Tout ça,
il faut... A la fois, il y a
une sorte d'urgence absolue
qui nous dépasse
et il faut beaucoup de nuance
et d'accompagnement dans la mise
en place. Les mêmes qui ont dit,
ça va pas assez vite,
disent, ça va trop vite.
-On va parler
de cet accomplissement.
Hélène Peskine,
les actions à envisager
sont nombreuses
et concernent les secteurs
des transports, des bâtiments,
de l'industrie,
l'énergie, l'agriculture.
Est-ce qu'il faut envisager
toutes ces actions en même temps
et lesquelles prioriser ?
-Je partage l'enthousiasme
justement parce qu'il existe
déjà des solutions
pour la partie décarbonation.
On n'a pas parlé encore
de l'adaptation aux effets
du changement climatique, un autre
enjeu socio-économique important.
Sur la baisse des émissions de gaz
à effet de serre, sur un certain
nombre d'objets
émettant du carbone, on a
des solutions, plus ou moins
efficaces à long terme.
Je pense à la voiture électrique
qui pourrait remplacer
la voiture thermique,
avec les risques d'effets pervers
de cette solution à long terme,
dont on ne mesure pas
les impacts,
mais qui arriveront peut-être.
En tout cas, on sait relativement
bien avoir un effet rapide
sur certaines
de ces émissions de carbone.
Sur la mobilité, véhicules lourds
comme légers, avec l'hydrogène.
Sur les bâtiments,
avec la rénovation,
mais aussi le réemploi,
le recyclage de l'urbanisation,
plutôt que l'étalement urbain
qui consomme de terres agricoles,
c'est le ZAN
dont vous parliez.
Mais aussi sur des solutions
agricoles moins gourmandes en eau
ou qui préservent le stockage
carbone dans les sols.
Ces choses-là sont connues,
elles ont un coût
et la question est de savoir
comment se répartit ce coût,
puisqu'il faut assez
rapidement arriver
à mettre en oeuvre ces solutions.
Quand un coût est insurmontable
ou insupportable pour un certain
nombre de décideurs,
dont les plus modestes,
il faut trouver les ajustements
ou les compensations nécessaires
pour les rendre supportables.
-Mais est-ce qu'il faut faire
tout en même temps
ou il y a des priorités ?
-Non seulement il faut faire tout
en même temps, mais il faut tester
plusieurs solutions.
Sur la mobilité,
la mobilité électrique,
mais avec des enjeux
sur les batteries pas durables,
la mobilité hydrogène,
pas complètement mature,
la non-mobilité, c'est-à-dire
réduire les déplacements,
par exemple en densifiant
l'urbanisation. Il faut évidemment
prendre toutes les solutions
à la fois. On a assez peu de temps.
On parle de l'horizon 2030
et de l'horizon 2050,
c'est moins de 10 ans
pour 2030 et 25 ans pour 2050.
On est assez peu capables
de développer des solutions
et de les massifier,
des nouvelles solutions,
technologies d'optimisation,
et de les massifier
à cet horizon-là.
Donc il faut tout prendre
et tester toutes les solutions.
A la fois construire plus sobrement,
c'est-à-dire
avec moins de matières premières
et rénover
avec les outils incitatifs
financiers
largement mis en place
par le gouvernement.
-Jean-Claude Mailly, au regard
des contingences sociales,
y a-t-il des choses
à faire avant d'autres
ou vous êtes aussi favorable
à ce que tout soit mis en chantier
en même temps ?
Mais par rapport
aux besoins des Français.
-Moi, j'ai rien
contre le fait de mettre
tous les chantiers en même temps.
Vous prenez les entreprises.
Les entreprises ont besoin
d'une vision à long terme.
On peut pas changer toutes
les 5 minutes d'orientation, etc.
Dans le même temps,
les pouvoirs publics,
c'est pas d'aujourd'hui,
on n'a pas la culture
de l'évaluation dans notre pays.
On évalue, parfois on évalue,
mais on ne tient pas compte,
à part les militaires
avec les retours d'expérience,
des résultats d'une évaluation.
On change pas
obligatoirement.
Il y a des exemples.
Brice Lalonde citait
les passoires thermiques.
Ca fait partie
d'une politique d'évaluation.
C'est pas simplement
est-ce que ça marche
techniquement, c'est socialement. Si
ça marche pas, on modifie. Ce sont
des éléments importants.
Il faut faire attention.
Je suis toujours inquiet
sur l'avenir de l'industrie
automobile dans notre pays.
2035, c'est quand même court.
Il faut pas l'oublier.
C'est des transformations profondes
des métiers,
des métiers moins qualifiés.
Que fera-t-on demain des batteries ?
Etc. Donc, voilà.
Il faudrait pas que l'industrie
automobile devienne la sidérurgie
des années 70, 80. Voilà. Donc,
il faut être très attentif
sur ces questions-là.
Obligatoirement, pour moi, les trois
doivent être pris en considération,
les exigences en matière d'écologie,
d'environnement,
les exigences en matière sociale
et les contraintes économiques.
Dernier point,
Brice Lalonde a raison,
est-ce qu'on sortira ou pas
des normes européennes ?
Des discussions sont en cours,
on verra ce que ça donne,
mais quand on voit par exemple
le dernier texte,
l'accord passé le 17 octobre
sur les questions électriques,
tant mieux, c'est un progrès,
mais quand même,
c'est bien la technocratie
européenne, compliquée.
-Brice Lalonde, vous allez répondre
à cette question des priorités,
mais je vous ai trouvé
très enthousiaste sur la prise
de conscience.
Comment vous expliquez le décalage
entre cette prise
de conscience enthousiaste
et le fait que,
dans tous les sondages
sur les priorités
des Français, ça apparaît
loin derrière la sécurité,
l'immigration, le pouvoir d'achat,
etc. ? Et qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire
pour faire remonter la question
écologique ?
-Il faut...
Nous avons besoin de dirigeants
enthousiastes, qui nous donnent
de l'espoir, qui nous entraînent
et qui nous montrent l'avenir.
-Les dirigeants actuels
ne donnent pas...
-Oui.
Oui, en effet.
Il y a une hésitation.
Et en France, c'est très frappant
par rapport à d'autres pays.
La France est pessimiste.
On est pour la décroissance,
des choses comme ça.
Allez discuter ailleurs,
en Chine, au Brésil,
aux Etats-Unis, etc.,
les gars, ils y croient.
Ils croient à la technique,
au progrès, aux entreprises.
Il y a un effort à faire
en France...
-Emmanuel Macron n'est pas
convaincu ?
-Il est convaincu.
-Mais ?
-Allez lui demander, c'est pas à moi
qu'il faut demander, n'est-ce pas ?
Le président de la République,
il est ondoyant,
on sait pas bien ce qu'il pense.
Maintenant, on a besoin de ça.
Quelle est la priorité ?
C'est l'électrification.
Tout le monde partage ce constat,
il faut électrifier,
parce qu'on peut
produire de l'électricité
de manière décarbonée. C'est urgent
d'avoir de l'électricité.
Donc ça veut dire, par exemple,
le ZAN, on n'a pas
le droit d'artificialiser
la nature, mais si on veut
mettre des centrales solaires
de 100 ha, il faut bien
de la place pour le faire.
Quelle est la priorité, là ?
Tous les espaces agricoles
ont-ils la même valeur
écologique
ou patrimoniale ou agricole ?
Mais certainement pas !
Il faut là aussi être flexible,
intelligent et choisir
les priorités.
Electrifier, ça veut dire
produire de l'électricité
et consommer de l'électricité.
Les voitures électriques, parfait,
mais nos constructeurs ont choisi
des grosses bagnoles
pour les riches. C'est pas
comme ça qu'on va y arriver.
Donc il faut des petites voitures
pour tous les Français.
Ca va commencer,
mais seulement l'an prochain.
Il faut accélérer. Et en revanche,
dans les bâtiments,
ça stagne, on n'électrifie pas.
Pourquoi ?
Le lobby du gaz s'y oppose.
Ah, mais il faut être courageux,
un petit peu. Dire au gaz,
ça suffit le gaz maintenant, c'est
la place au décarboné.
Il faut là aussi de la volonté
et il faut s'y tenir. Mais il faut
être flexible, il faut être
un peu intelligent quand même.
-Hélène Peskine ?
-La transition
écologique, c'est aussi une question
de sécurité et de pouvoir d'achat.
On pose peut-être mal
la question dans ces sondages.
Quand le prix de l'énergie augmente
ou même on menace
de couper l'électricité,
comme au début de l'hiver dernier,
les Français se rendent compte
qu'ils doivent modifier
leur système de chauffage
ou réduire leur consommation.
Et ils y arrivent.
Ils sont volontaires.
Face à des chocs
de pouvoir d'achat,
liés à ces questions
de transition, de ressource
ou d'approvisionnement,
il y a pas de doute sur la solution.
Et sur la question de la sécurité,
on a en ce moment
dans les Hauts-de-France
des inondations catastrophiques, les
gens qui les ont vécues, qui sont
de plus en plus nombreux
et dans de plus
en plus de régions, la vallée
de la Roya, derrière Nice, etc.,
ces gens ont en tête que leur mode
de vie ou leur manière
de... de s'installer
sur le sol en France n'est pas
complètement sûre. Donc,
cette question de sécurité,
d'assurance de leur logement,
de leur capacité à transmettre,
est interrogée par ces enjeux
écologiques. C'est un peu
compliqué de séparer
comme ça les questions.
-M. Jean-René Cazeneuve, au regard
de vos compétences
et comme rapporteur général
de la commission des finances
à l'Assemblée nationale,
je voudrais vous interroger
sur une proposition
du rapport Pisani-Ferry
Mahfouz pour France Stratégie,
l'ancien Haut-Commissariat au Plan.
Au niveau des investissements requis
et pour arriver,
si je puis dire, à assumer
nos objectifs, il propose
un impôt exceptionnel
pour permettre et rendre possible
la planification écologique.
Est-ce que vous êtes favorable
à cette proposition
et est-ce qu'elle est réalisable
au regard
de la situation économique ?
-Si vous me permettez,
avant de répondre directement
à votre question, j'aimerais
rebondir sur 2, 3 choses.
Tout n'est pas qu'un sujet d'argent.
Je sais bien que c'est le thème.
Je vais vous prendre 2 exemples.
Dans la loi de finances,
on a voté 2,5 milliards, je crois,
pour MaPrimeRénov',
donc pour aider.
On ne les a pas utilisés en 2023.
On vient de faire voter
la loi de fin de gestion,
on ne les a pas
utilisés totalement.
Pourquoi ?
Parce qu'il y a un accompagnement.
Est-ce qu'on a assez
d'entreprises formées pour ça ?
Assez de gens qui sont prêts
à le faire pour ça ?
On aurait pu doubler
ou tripler ce budget-là,
on aurait été incapables
de les utiliser.
2e point, je rebondis
sur ce que dit M. Mailly. Sur le...
...notre capacité
à nous transformer,
il faut se transformer.
Le problème,
c'est que la valeur ajoutée
créée
par cette transition écologique,
n'est... ne remplace pas
la valeur ajoutée actuelle
avec les mêmes personnes
et aux mêmes endroits.
Je suis du Sud-Ouest.
Dans l'Aveyron, il y a
la fermeture
de cette usine qui faisait
des carburateurs pour le diesel.
Il y a plus de voitures diesel,
on ferme.
On va recréer de la valeur,
avec des batteries
électriques, ailleurs
avec d'autres personnes.
A quelle vitesse socialement
on est capables de former, de faire
en sorte
que les entreprises se forment
et d'accompagner les gens
qui vont être victimes
de cette transformation.
Pour le financement,
moi, j'y suis favorable.
Moi, j'y suis favorable.
Mais ça ne peut être
qu'une réflexion européenne.
Et c'est d'ailleurs ce que pousse
à faire Pisani-Ferry.
J'y suis favorable. Aujourd'hui,
heureusement, on n'est pas non plus,
vous avez dit
que les plus riches étaient
les plus grands consommateurs,
c'est vrai, émetteurs, c'est vrai.
Absolument. Ce sont quand même
aujourd'hui, ceux qui contribuent
le plus d'un point de vue imposition
et aujourd'hui,
les aides sont liées aux revenus.
Vous avez des aides
pour changer de voiture,
pour changer
vos fenêtres, votre chaudière
et qui sont liées
à des niveaux de revenus.
Donc heureusement,
cette justice sociale est en place.
Est-elle suffisante,
importante, on peut en discuter.
En tout cas,
la machine est en place.
Je suis favorable, mais ça ne peut
être qu'européen, parce que
le niveau d'imposition en France
est très élevé.
Si vous voulez, on se bat,
notre majorité se bat,
là aussi, c'est un propos politique,
j'en suis désolé,
pour que notre pays soit attractif
d'un point de vue économique,
pour réindustrialiser notre pays,
pour ne pas dépendre
du reste du globe...
-M. Cazeneuve, sur le plan européen,
vous savez
que c'est très difficile. Regardez
comment ça se passe...
-On va y arriver.
-...pour le marché de l'électricité,
regardez
les oppositions de l'Allemagne
à subventionner
notre nucléaire décarboné, etc.
-Regardez...
-Non, mais je voudrais
vous poser
une question très précise.
Si on devait imposer,
est-ce que vous êtes
favorable à ce qu'on impose,
à ce que cet impôt exceptionnel
soit porté plus spécialement
par les entreprises
qui ont des dividendes
exceptionnels,
notamment au sein du CAC 40.
On l'a dit, c'est
insupportable
pour les classes moyennes.
Est-ce qu'il peut porter
sur certaines catégories ?
-Ecoutez, alors là, je...
Je suis désolé de vous dire ça,
mais on mélange
un peu les sujets. Bon.
On peut y arriver au niveau
européen, on y est arrivés
sur l'imposition minimale
au sein de l'OCDE.
Aujourd'hui, à partir de 2024,
vous aurez dans le monde entier
un niveau d'imposition
des entreprises à 15 % minimum.
Est-ce que c'est assez ?
On est arrivés
à avoir cette vision globale.
La transition écologique
est un sujet global.
Il y a pas plus global que ce sujet.
Donc, sur l'imposition,
il faut le faire.
Si vous imposez les entreprises,
les grandes entreprises,
je veux bien,
c'est grand, donc c'est
épouvantable.
-On parle pas d'épouvantable,
on parle de résultats...
-Si, derrière...
-Non, il est pas question...
Non, ma question n'est pas
du tout morale. Elle est qu'on prend
l'argent là où on le trouve.
-Les entreprises aujourd'hui
participent évidemment
et ont des contributions fortes.
C'est le pays où les prélèvements
obligatoires sur les entreprises
sont les plus élevés d'Europe.
Ca devrait nous calmer
sur l'efficacité
de l'augmentation de l'imposition.
Mais qu'est-ce que vous faites ?
Si vous avez un écart d'imposition
plus important sur les entreprises
en France qu'ailleurs,
les entreprises déménagent.
Si elles déménagent, vous avez
moins de recettes sociales,
moins de recettes fiscales, etc.
On a fait ça des dizaines d'années,
on a été champions du monde
de la fiscalité.
On a eu un chômage endémique
et on a perdu
toute souveraineté industrielle.
On n'est pas dans cette logique-là.
Oui, il faut chercher des moyens,
mais globalement,
au niveau européen.
C'est la bonne échelle.
-Jean-Claude Mailly,
sur cet impôt exceptionnel,
sur cet investissement ?
-J'y suis favorable,
y compris si cet impôt
doit être temporaire
d'une manière ou d'une autre.
Mais globalement,
on a un problème de fiscalité
en France depuis très longtemps.
Les gens sont pas contre
payer l'impôt.
Le problème est qu'ils ont
le sentiment que ceux qui sont
dans la même situation
devraient payer la même chose
et ne paient pas.
Il y a un sentiment profond,
pas nouveau,
d'iniquité du système fiscal.
Ce qui vaut pour les citoyens
vaut pour les entreprises.
Entre la PME et la multinationale.
Si on travaille pas à un moment
sur ces questions plus globalement,
on n'y arrivera pas. Je suis pour
une imposition exceptionnelle,
même si elle est temporaire.
Maintenant,
c'est vrai qu'en économie
de marché, la compétitivité,
ça existe toujours.
D'une manière ou d'une autre.
Le gouvernement allemand
vient d'annoncer
aujourd'hui que, considérant
que certaines entreprises allemandes
sont venues en France,
parce que le coût de l'électricité
pour les entreprises est moins cher,
un plan de 12 milliards d'euros
de réduction des taxes.
C'est dans une logique
qui est purement
de compétitivité. Et l'Europe,
c'est un monstre difficile à bouger.
A 27, c'est très compliqué.
-Brice Lalonde, on évoque
beaucoup l'électrification.
Vous l'avez évoquée.
Certains considèrent
et vous-même le considérez
que l'électrification aujourd'hui
est une priorité,
que par ailleurs
de nombreux industriels, mais aussi
de grands esprits,
considèrent qu'on ne peut pas
réindustrialiser
sans une électrification.
Seriez-vous favorable
à ce qu'il y ait un impôt
ou, en tout cas,
trouver des investissements,
pour permettre
à la filière nucléaire
française de porter le projet
de la réindustrialisation ?
-Alors,
ce qui est vrai,
c'est qu'on ne réussit pas
la décarbonation
sans réindustrialiser.
C'est un peu compliqué
à faire comprendre,
notamment à ceux
qui veulent la décroissance.
Si on veut décarboner,
il va falloir des électrolyses,
des pompes à chaleur, des batteries
pour les bagnoles, il va falloir
recycler ces batteries, donc
des usines aussi grandes. Enfin,
il va falloir investir
et en effet faire attention
à ce que les impôts de production
ne soient pas trop élevés ou on n'y
arrivera jamais. Je suis d'accord
avec le rapporteur.
Absolument.
Et je voulais reprendre
ce que dit Mme Peskine.
Elle a dit que peut-être
que la fiscalité pourrait être aussi
assise sur les émissions
de gaz à effet de serre.
C'est bien ça, le problème.
Donc, essayons de trouver
une espèce de combinaison de moyens
de financement. Il y a de l'emprunt.
Il faudrait emprunter.
Peut-être qu'on peut faire
un grand emprunt national français.
On l'a fait autrefois.
Les gens seront peut-être heureux
de contribuer à l'effort. Et puis,
il y a les taxes, la fiscalité, etc.
Donc soyons un peu inventifs.
Et puis, ce que je disais au départ,
c'est que la limite des 3 %,
c'est terminé, ça a volé en éclats.
Et donc, il va falloir
sortir. La transition doit sortir
de ces histoires-là.
Il faut qu'on ait
un budget à part, différent,
comme à la Libération.
-Comment on finance
la filière nucléaire,
qui a besoin
de très gros investissements ?
-Alors, elle a besoin de très gros
investissements surtout pour...
Comment ça s'appelle ?
-Pour le nouveau nucléaire.
-Non ! Pas pour le nouveau.
Pour le carénage, merci !
Surtout pour le carénage.
-Non, le carénage
est une chose,
mais le discours de Belfort
propose 6 plus 8 nouveaux réacteurs.
Cela représente une quantité
de milliards d'euros.
-Oui.
-Comment
vous financez ça ?
-Demandez à EDF.
On a cette discussion en ce moment
sur le prix de l'électricité.
Une partie du financement vient
du coût de l'électricité.
Que voulez-vous ?
Il faut que le gouvernement accepte
que l'entreprise
EDF est une entreprise.
Si c'est pas une entreprise,
c'est un service public,
une administration de l'Etat.
Si c'est pas ça,
il faut que normalement,
dans le prix de l'électricité,
elle finance
son fonctionnement
et ses investissements. Une partie
viendra de là.
Une autre partie viendra sans doute
des aides de l'Etat acceptées
par l'Union européenne. Il y a une
chose très nouvelle dans l'Europe,
elle a compris que c'était pas
uniquement un truc de consommateurs,
c'est aussi un truc de producteurs.
Pour la 1re fois, l'Europe a accepté
des politiques industrielles.
Dans ce cadre-là,
je crois que Mme Pannier-Runacher
s'est beaucoup battue pour ça,
l'Europe accepte qu'il y ait
des financements dans la taxonomie
pour le nucléaire.
-La pensée, on l'a affichée,
d'Edouard Philippe :
"Il n'y a pas de démocratie
qui subsiste durablement
"à une érosion continue du pouvoir
d'achat des classes moyennes."
Alors, justement,
Jean-Claude Mailly,
ces classes moyennes voient
une stagnation
de leur pouvoir d'achat.
L'inflation était durable,
même si elle a baissé, elle reste
quand même à un niveau important.
Les privations
au niveau des consommations,
même primaires,
se manifestent. Les gens
consomment moins, etc.
Comment arriver dans ce contexte
à obtenir leur assentiment
sur des projets
ambitieux et coûteux ?
-Il y a deux choses.
Enfin, de ce que je ressens moi.
D'abord,
Brice Lalonde disait, les Français
sont un peuple pessimiste
par rapport à d'autres.
J'ai une explication pour ça.
Le peuple français est
un peuple très politique.
Ca veut dire qu'il attend énormément
de ses gouvernants.
Et quand il est déçu
de ses gouvernants,
on voit ce qu'il arrive.
Ca a pas été
aujourd'hui, mais ça a été valable
hier. Après, la question,
tous les sondages aujourd'hui
montrent que la question prioritaire
dans les réponses aux sondages,
c'est la question
du pouvoir d'achat.
Même pendant la période actuelle,
le pouvoir d'achat n'a pas été
maintenu, malgré... y compris
quand on regarde
les négociations de salaires
dans le secteur privé,
encore pire dans le secteur public.
La perte est plus élevée
dans le public
qu'elle ne l'est globalement
dans le privé. Il faut savoir
répondre à cette question.
Alors, le gouvernement
a fait une conférence sociale,
il n'y a
pas longtemps. Je regrette
que certaines des décisions
qu'il a annoncées,
j'étais avec d'autres, on poussait
pour ça depuis pas mal d'années,
vont dans le bon sens,
pourquoi attendre 6 mois
avant de les mettre en oeuvre ?
Le salaire minimum
dans les branches,
par exemple, qui pourrait jouer
un rôle de booster
dans les négociations salariales.
Mais ce qui est vrai, j'allais dire,
pour une fois, je suis d'accord
avec Edouard Philippe,
mais la question du pouvoir d'achat
et sa dégradation des classes
moyennes, ça porte atteinte
à la démocratie. Enfin, ça participe
à la montée des populismes,
de gauche ou de droite.
-Jean-Claude Mailly,
ici même dans une émission,
Daniel Cohen, un économiste
qui nous a quittés,
disait qu'il y avait un phénomène
intéressant
d'un point de vue économique,
c'est qu'à mesure
que le progrès social avance,
les inégalités sociales
se creusent. C'est-à-dire qu'on vit
cette espèce de contradiction.
Est-ce que vous,
vous suggéreriez au gouvernement
de faire une conférence
ou des états généraux
sur les inégalités sociales
qui persistent
et qui s'aggravent
dans certaines catégories
de la population ?
-Sur certains points,
ça a été évoqué
lors de la conférence sociale,
c'était un des thèmes
de la conférence.
Mais il faut maintenant agir,
on ne peut pas se contenter de dire,
si, dans 6 mois, les employeurs
ou les branches en question,
n'ont pas répondu,
on sera plus méchants.
Non. Il faut faire les choses
dès maintenant.
La question des inégalités est
à la fois une question d'emploi,
c'est évident, même si
le chômage a décliné, mais il risque
malheureusement de remonter
dans les mois à venir.
C'est pour moi toujours une question
de fiscalité également, d'iniquité
dans la fiscalité et on peut
très bien effectivement... Bon,
je suis pas non plus pour
la multiplication des conférences,
quel que soit leur nom.
Je remarque quand même, ça,
c'est l'ancien qui parle,
que c'est la 1re fois
qu'une conférence sociale,
sommet social,
comme vous voulez, ne soit pas
faite en présence du président
de la République.
-C'est un manque.
-Une erreur selon moi.
-Hélène Peskine, on va rentrer
dans les difficultés
et dans les propositions
qui peuvent être faites.
Face aux difficultés
socio-économiques, que vient
d'évoquer Jean-Claude Mailly,
de nos concitoyens,
de nombreux responsables politiques
au sein de la majorité proposent
de temporiser. Qui sur la location
immobilière
des passoires thermiques. Qui
sur l'artificialisation des sols
et de manière plus générale
qui en viennent à considérer
que la transition écologique
est spontanément inégalitaire
pour les classes moyennes.
Qu'est-ce que vous en pensez ?
-Le progrès environnemental,
c'est...
-Et ce sont pas des réactionnaires
qui disent ça. Je ne les cite pas,
mais ils sont nombreux.
-Je pense sincèrement
que le progrès environnemental,
c'est du progrès social.
Notamment car les personnes
les plus fragiles ou vulnérables
du point de vue de l'environnement,
qui habitent à côté des autoroutes,
dans les passoires thermiques,
dans les zones fragilisées
par l'érosion du littoral,
sont les personnes
les plus modestes, les plus pauvres,
à l'échelle mondiale
comme française.
Faire du progrès environnemental
et mettre en avant
la nécessité d'aller vite,
c'est aussi du progrès social.
C'est un point
très important. Si on a ça en tête,
il y a une logique,
une forme de redistribution
des bénéfices environnementaux
vers les plus fragiles.
En Allemagne, on a mis en place
un billet de train pour prendre
les transports décarbonés
à 49 euros pour tous les jeunes
et les personnes qui prennent
ces trains, c'est une incitation
des classes moyennes
à se déplacer de manière décarbonée.
Les Espagnols ont fait de même.
En Grande-Bretagne, on a
renoncé à faire un TGV pour aller
dans le nord, vers Manchester.
On a des politiques publiques
qui peuvent
aller dans le sens d'une forme
de socialisation du bénéfice
environnemental
et de faire du progrès social
grâce à la transition.
Sur la question de temporiser,
je suis pas favorable à temporiser,
car c'est au détriment
des plus fragiles.
-Jean-René Cazeneuve, puisque
vous êtes politique, vous appartenez
à la majorité présidentielle,
des responsables
de cette majorité
et non des moindres,
on peut citer
Edouard Philippe, Jean-Louis
Bourlanges, dans une déclaration
récente : "La politique
"de transition énergétique
est une machine à exploser."
Est-ce que ceux qui mettent
en garde, par exemple,
en disant, on ne...
c'est un problème
difficile à résoudre immédiatement
que d'empêcher
la location immobilière
de passoires thermiques
ou ceux qui disent
qu'une artificialisation zéro
des sols est impossible...
Est-ce que vous pensez
que ces gens-là sont des...
...des opposants
ou est-ce que vous pensez
qu'il y a du bon sens
là-dedans ?
-Non, ce sont
deux personnes formidables,
mais je pense qu'il y a
un petit problème de jugement.
Pas de problème à leur dire.
S'ils étaient là, je leur dirais
aussi franchement.
On ne peut pas...
On ne peut pas ralentir.
Tout nous dit qu'il faut accélérer.
Tout nous dit qu'on est en retard.
-Est-ce que, par exemple,
pour la location
des passoires thermiques...
-Bon exemple.
-Alors ?
-Ca concerne qui,
ces passoires thermiques ?
Ca concerne ceux
qui sont propriétaires
de leur maison ? Non.
Ca concerne
les plus pauvres qui louent ? Non.
Ce sont les victimes.
Ca ne concerne que les propriétaires
qui font de la location
au moment
où ils vont changer de locataire,
c'est-à-dire ça va
s'échelonner dans le temps,
on commence par les vraies
passoires thermiques, les G,
et on parle de 1,7 million
de logements.
Donc...
pourquoi on a fait comme ça ?
Pourquoi on a fait
progressivement jusqu'en 2035,
je crois, pour les...
Parce que, justement,
que les gens se préparent.
On est partis du principe que
quelqu'un qui loue, d'accord,
quelqu'un qui a un bien,
quand il le loue,
il en tire un revenu,
c'est pas complètement anormal
qu'il prenne une partie
de ce revenu pour rénover.
La principale victime,
et vous l'avez très bien dit,
Madame,
c'est quand même la personne qui est
le locataire, qui est
dans une passoire thermique
et à qui on dit :
"Continuez dans la passoire
thermique." C'est elle
qui paie la facture.
Et le propriétaire,
il prend le loyer.
-Prenons l'exemple
des logements, de l'habitat,
on a refait une émission ici,
il y avait un accord
unanime,
peut-être que c'était orienté,
je ne le crois pas, politiquement,
pour dire que la question
du logement, elle a été
maltraitée,
elle reste explosive, etc.
Par rapport à l'artificialisation
des sols et au fait
qu'il manque énormément
de logements, diriez-vous que
c'est un faux problème
que de poser la question comme ça ?
-Non.
Je pense
qu'il faut être honnête,
je crois, et se dire
que cette transformation écologique,
elle va faire mal.
Si on pense que va se faire ça
sans imposition supplémentaire,
sans efforts, sans changer
nos comportements
et nos habitudes,
on se raconte des histoires.
C'est compliqué.
Ce qui nous attend
est un effort compliqué.
Il faut que ce soit réparti
le plus justement
pour être accepté.
Chacun va devoir s'y mettre,
si vous voulez.
Et donc, sur le ZAN...
Bon...
-Vous pouvez expliquer ?
-Zéro artificialisation nette.
On dit pas qu'on arrête
du jour au lendemain.
Le terme a été
mal choisi.
On dit qu'on veut arrêter
d'artificialiser
à horizon 2050.
Dans les 10 prochaines années,
on veut simplement
réduire de 50 %
l'artificialisation des sols.
Il y a pas un mec sérieux
qui peut dire
que si on se met à transformer
tous les terrains agricoles
en résidences secondaires,
en parkings et je ne sais quoi,
c'est bon pour la planète.
Tout le monde sait
qu'il faut arrêter ça.
Il y a plein de solutions.
Il y a plein de friches.
On peut parfaitement densifier.
Je suis
dans un territoire rural,
je vais le dire,
je vais me faire gronder,
mais il y a pas
un immeuble de 2 étages
dans mon département.
Peut-être quelques-uns.
Il y en a très très peu.
Donc on peut
parfaitement densifier.
Les usines,
il y en a pas beaucoup,
mais les établissements industriels,
ils sont répartis,
ils sont tous
entourés de parkings.
Il faut concevoir
cette densification,
et le faire intelligemment.
Ca demande de la concertation,
il faut le faire
avec les collectivités
territoriales
et les acteurs sociaux.
C'est ce qui manque aujourd'hui.
Les gens voient
la décision du politique,
ou pas, et ils ont l'impression,
d'un coup...
Evidemment, il y a
une série d'agitateurs,
de populistes,
qui alimentent
ces peurs...
"Attention, vous êtes tous dehors !"
La loi sur les passoires
thermiques,
elle serait responsable
du problème de logement.
Ca me fait doucement rigoler.
Elle s'applique
qu'à partir de 2025.
Elle est pas du tout responsable,
et pourtant, on va dire :
"Et le problème..."
Pareil pour le ZAN.
Les décrets sont pas sortis.
On a voté une loi
pour la dater, mais c'est
à cause de ça aujourd'hui...
Non ! Je crois
qu'il faut...
Il y a...
C'est un chantier fabuleux
et je crois aussi
qu'il est enthousiasmant.
D'accord ?
Comment on adapte notre pays,
notre économie,
nos comportements individuels,
à cette obligation
de la transition écologique ?
Et donc, il faut se fixer
des objectifs collectifs.
Quand c'est dans la loi,
c'est collectif.
C'est la représentation
qui décide.
Après, comment on aligne
- et c'est très complexe -
les moyens, les financements,
cet accompagnement...
Mais reculer aujourd'hui,
ou freiner aujourd'hui,
ne me paraît pas être
la bonne attitude.
-Ecoutez,
on va conclure là-dessus,
sur cette question-là.
Est-ce que...
Dans la compétitivité
économique mondiale,
quand on voit
les budgets consacrés
par la Chine
ou les investissements
des Etats-Unis,
notamment dans l'attraction
industrielle,
la décarbonation écologique,
on se rend compte
que l'Union Européenne peine
à aller de l'avant
et à se montrer
à son tour compétitive.
Hélène Peskine,
est-ce que vous pensez
qu'à ce niveau-là,
un ajustement,
notamment
avec une taxe carbone,
mais une véritable
taxe carbone,
nous permettrait
d'aller de l'avant
ou à quel autre moyen
on peut faire appel
pour être compétitif ?
Parce que nous sommes...
L'Europe est en face de la Chine,
en face des Etats-Unis,
dans ce domaine.
-Ca a été dit,
déjà un peu
par Brice Lalonde,
un des enjeux
de la décarbonation,
c'est de rapprocher la production
de la consommation
et donc d'avoir à proximité,
dans l'espace européen,
de quoi nourrir
le projet industriel,
énergétique
et écologique européen.
A priori, la solution idéale,
c'est la taxe carbone
aux frontières,
telle qu'elle commence
à être mise en oeuvre.
-A combien
pour qu'elle soit efficace ?
-Je saurais pas dire.
En tout cas, il faut donner un prix
au carbone et considérer
que le carbone importé
doit être réduit au minimum
dans le monde
de la consommation en Europe.
Mais ça pose
un certain nombre
de questions d'adaptation,
par filière, par outils, par objets,
par chaîne de valeur.
Et ça,
c'est sans doute aujourd'hui
ce qu'on a pas bien fait
en Europe.
On n'arrive pas à mesure
à quel endroit de la chaîne
d'approvisionnement donnée,
sur un objet ou un outil industriel.
On a intérêt à mettre
cette barrière à l'entrée.
Sinon, on risque de perdre
de la compétitivité.
Je pense à l'acier, par exemple,
ou d'autres filières.
Il y a certainement
à être plus subtil
sur la manière
dont on va mettre en place,
en concertation avec ces filières
à l'échelle européenne,
ces outils
de taxation frontière.
Mais pour moi,
c'est l'outil "idéal",
le plus compréhensible par tous
et le plus logique,
pour protéger
un espace de marché,
qui est l'espace
qui consomme le plus dans le monde.
Les consommateurs riches
en Europe,
c'est le Graal
des producteurs
américains et chinois
pour vendre leur production.
-Merci.
Jean-Claude Mailly ?
La compétitivité, comment
on l'assure au niveau européen ?
-Je suis aussi favorable
à une taxe carbone
à la frontière européenne.
Ca, ça me paraît évident.
Après, c'est effectivement
complexe à mettre en place,
mais il faut y aller.
Je pense que l'Europe,
globalement,
économiquement, politiquement,
y compris géopolitiquement,
on voit bien
que c'est un nain
par rapport aux Etats-Unis,
la Russie
et la Chine,
y compris économiquement.
Je pense qu'au-delà des critères
économiques qu'il faut revoir...
Ca fait longtemps
que je suis partisan
des cercles concentriques.
Il n'y a aucune raison
que des pays,
au sein de l'Union européenne,
ne puissent pas décider
d'aller plus vite
et plus loin,
y compris sur l'harmonisation
de leurs politiques
fiscales et sociales.
Tant qu'on ne travaillera pas
ces questions,
on aura toujours
des difficultés
à prendre des décisions
en Europe.
-M. Lalonde, taxe carbone ?
Et combien ?
-L'un des objectifs de la politique
énergétique, c'est la souveraineté.
La souveraineté européenne
nous est importante.
Mais alors, comment on fait ?
Par exemple,
tous les panneaux photovoltaïques
sont fabriqués en Chine.
Certains disent :
"Ben, tiens,
"mettons une taxe parce que...
"ces panneaux photovoltaïques
sont fabriqués avec du charbon.
"Le contenu carbone de ces panneaux
ne nous convient pas."
Faisons ça
chez nous,
ça nous coûtera plus cher.
En même temps,
si on disait :
"Acceptons d'importer
ces panneaux,
"puisque ces panneaux
photovoltaïques vont
"contribuer
à notre souveraineté."
Ah... C'est compliqué.
Donc, en réalité,
soyons intelligents.
C'est ça, le truc final :
soyons intelligents,
nom d'un chien !
-Jean-René Cazeneuve,
sur ce point-là ?
Cette taxe carbone,
qu'on évoque
comme un serpent de mer,
et qui vient pas ?
-Si, ça y est,
elle a été votée...
-Elle est compétitive
à quel niveau ?
-Elle est en train
de se mettre en place.
C'est très compliqué,
elle est sur l'acier.
-Elle est corrélée
au marché ETS,
de toute manière.
Ca passe par...
-Même l'Europe
a été précurseur de ça.
-Oui, oui.
-Votre avis là-dessus.
-Ca dit que, pour moi,
ce sujet-là,
les réponses sont européennes.
Je suis...
un Européen convaincu.
Effectivement, il faut se protéger.
Il faut faire attention.
Si vous protégez
les taxes carbones,
les autres font pareil.
Quand on voit ce qui se passe
d'un point de vue géopolitique,
l'Europe, c'est vraiment
le minimum de la taille...
-Une dernière question.
Vous appartenez à la majorité
et vous avez
des fonctions importantes
au sein de cette majorité.
A votre avis,
les élections européennes
vont se jouer sur quoi ?
Sur quel thème essentiel ?
Est-ce que, par rapport
à notre discussion
écologique et sociale,
vous pensez
que ça fera partie
du package électoral ?
-Je crois
qu'avec ce qui se passe en Ukraine,
les questions de sécurité
vont être évidemment
extrêmement importantes.
Avec ce qui se passe...
en Italie, en particulier,
et en Allemagne, aujourd'hui,
les questions d'immigration
vont être aussi...
centrales.
Le sujet du pouvoir d'achat,
il n'est pas que français.
On est même relativement protégés,
notre inflation est plus faible.
-Pour que ce soit plus soft,
vous pensez qu'il faut mettre
un peu de climat, d'écologie,
pousser ces questions-là ?
-Moi, j'espère.
J'espère et je crois
que l'Europe
aujourd'hui est moteur
sur ces questions-là.
On vote en France
les lois européennes
avec du retard,
un décalage.
Sur certains sujets,
on a été moteur
suite à la convention citoyenne,
en particulier.
Pour d'autres,
il faut
que l'Europe nous aide.
L'Europe,
c'est aussi enthousiasmant.
Il faut qu'elle le reste.
-Merci.
Ecoutez, je vais vous présenter
une brève bibliographie.
Je voudrais
signaler le rapport,
qu'on a longuement évoqué
dans cette émission,
de Jean Pisani-Ferry
et Selma Mahfouz,
"Les incidences économiques
de l'action pour le climat".
Une publication
France Stratégie.
Je voudrais
évoquer un livre de Lucas Chancel.
"Insoutenables inégalités :
"pour une justice sociale
et environnementale",
éditions Les Petits Matins.
En deux mots,
Hélène Peskine ?
-Lucas Chancel, un économiste,
a travaillé
avec Thomas Piketty
sur le rapport sur l'égalité
et sa spécialité,
c'est les inégalités
environnementales.
Cet ouvrage,
c'est la restitution
de la partie du rapport
qui concerne les vulnérabilités
environnementales.
C'est de lui que viennent
les budgets carbone par personne
en Europe et dans le monde.
C'est une manière de relativiser
la part des émissions
de gaz à effet de serre
en fonction du niveau de vie
et des inégalités sociales.
-Hélène Peskine,
en tant que responsable du PUCA,
vous avez de nombreuses
publications.
Est-ce qu'il y en a une dernière
qui est en lien
avec les thèmes évoqués ?
-Un thème qu'on n'a pas eu
le temps d'aborder,
c'est l'adaptation.
Avec l'accélération
des effets du changement climatique,
on a des effets qui ont
des conséquences sociales
de vulnérabilité renforcée
de certains territoires.
En l'occurrence,
on a travaillé au PUCA
sur ces territoires
littoraux en outre-mer.
L'ouvrage
"Territoires submergés"
concerne Saint-Pierre-et-Miquelon
et la Martinique, en particulier,
avec des bourgs qui sont menacés
par la montée des eaux.
C'est des questions
qui se rencontrent
dans le monde entier,
avec derrière, des enjeux sociaux
et de populations
qui sont colossaux.
Cet ouvrage est un peu
une tentative de décrire
le monde vers lequel on va
finalement à l'échéance des effets
du changement climatique.
-Merci.
Brice Lalonde, je rappelle
que vous continuez
à déranger un petit peu.
"Excusez-moi de vous déranger,"
L'aube.
Il faut encore...
que le militantisme continue.
Il faut déranger pour faire
prendre conscience des enjeux.
-Il faut arrêter les guerres !
55... 5,5 % au moins des émissions
de gaz à effet de serre,
c'est les tanks,
les chars, etc.
Et puis, si on fait la guerre,
on fera pas...
On va pas lutter
contre le changement climatique.
Il faut arrêter les guerres.
-Merci, Brice Lalonde.
Ecoutez...
Merci, madame.
Merci, messieurs,
d'avoir participé
à la conversation
qui était à la fois féconde
et fructueuse.
Je voudrais remercier
l'équipe de LCP,
qui a permis la réalisation
de cette émission.
Avant de nous quitter, j'aimerais
vous soumettre cette pensée
de Bertrand Piccard,
qui est à la fois psychiatre
et qui anime la fondation
Solar Impulse :
"L'écologie peut aujourd'hui
booster l'économie
"grâce à toutes les solutions
efficientes
"et aux opportunités
industrielles propres."
SOUS-TITRAGE : RED BEE MEDIA